well have you seen the movie yes how was
it for you to watch your life you see I
yes I loved it definitely did I like it
you did a great job minutes Lee it's
entertainment so much different than
than the book it's like apples and
oranges
that's what we all saw the view is that
you are fantastic actor that Brian is no
you are oh really cause it's a little
harder when you have to do it for real
right yeah and your life depends all
right so molested you try not to act
when you're working on a gurney trying
to be is I try to be as much like this
as I am I'm not big and loud i couldn't
do that for two years and be convincing
so you really have to work inside your
own skin we make a created in person
robert musella was an italian-american
from new york city area who had a
business background and accounting
background
worked in a bank and work in a brokerage
firm and a
those things are true to me same age
same high I sometimes tell people with
them because there's none undercover
school but you go through to be
certified to do this type of work and
there's psychologists that are involved
in that process and I often get asked
the question of know why did they have
psychologists involvement
it's to determine if you're adequately
crazy really you really do need to go
through a lot of you're prepared for the
normal reaction to an abnormal
environment experience some some change
before i started doing undercover work
out of six foot two on here watching a
movie for us it's like two hours of
feeling this distension that for you
it's been a lifetime of that I don't
deal with it you know one of the things
that's important for everybody to
realize is that I'm just one of a
hundred plus people who have done that
type of work there were 40 people in my
undercover training school and so
although the experience is unique and
what happened once we got involved with
the bad guys and stuff to present a
different route there are a lot of
public servants out there that do this
type of work so it's not really all that
you need to me i got the unique
opportunity to tell the story because
Brad fell on within Helen did a great
job and everybody else did a fantastic
job putting together but you can train
to kind of have two brains at the same
time when you're working undercover
there times when I would be with people
and when I was in a meeting one time and
I was accused of being an undercover
agent how do you deal with that then we
really gentlemen train you how to deal
with that but you you kind of suppress
all of the my hair's on fire and then
one brain that doesn't come out and it
gets suppressed and the other one has to
take on the air of this persona that now
completely different
and then you have to really act that way
and not act like an agent and it's a
difficult that was an agent for 14 years
before ending the undercover work so
it's pretty easy to try to slip back
into acting like an agent not acting
like a bad guy who you're supposed to be
but I had a lot of great trainers I'm
growing I was really blessed in my
career I had great management that gave
me the opportunity but really take my
time to put this identity together and a
great partner and I you guys probably
aren't tough to tampa bay buccaneers
fans liking it to the Super Bowl
champion 2002 bucks they have it okay
quarterback and a great team are Alan I
was an okay lead undercover I think and
I had a great team around me and I'd
really got the benefit of that do you
have like a happy place or like some
sort of process that you
in your head when you're wearing like
the most complicated time like to just
calm yourself well you name only yeah
they train you to when you're in
training you know they try to help you
to understand the kind of stress that
you're going to wind up going through
and so you know eating right getting
enough sleep and all those things that
you know you're supposed to do that you
don't do and
so that helps some but you know for me
it's taken me the experience on writing
this book to me what really drove me my
heroin was getting new information and
that's what really kept me alive and
going after thing everything everything
gave me the energy night
guess that I had like there's like any
other drug he could get too much of it
it's not good
the last four or five months of the
operation now I probably realized that I
was so intent on trying to get more
information that i probably didn't feel
risks and maybe that I need to do
it was the information in trophy one you
also had to drink a lot was the guys
well and other things no spoilers you
know you had to be among family as the
family did you know we built I built
into that an angle that I think helped
me to deflect a lot of what public may
perceive was your another cover agency
we've got to do with the bad guys Tony
to do and it's not the case I mean
that's right actually a sign of weakness
I played the role of a money launderer
for a mythical mob I had two informants
within one of the five crime families in
New York real monsters and they gave me
a lot of Street credibility and when I
dealt with the Colombian cartels I and
they wanted me to do things that I
didn't want to do my easy comeback was I
work for my family you're the cherry on
top of the cake I've been given the
authorization to check the Latin
American markets to see how much we can
make but I cannot ruin what I'm doing
with my family and if they see the
greatness and I can't control myself I'm
going to be killed so you're going to
have to do it my way or just not
can do that and that was accepted it was
respected how was it for you to get this
story out there the book came out at
around two thousand nine now with the
film how is it for you I mean why did
you want to tell it and how is it for
you to live with it every day knowing
that it is out there it's an incredible
story but it's also your life yeah well
I keep going back to a team's life but I
think that I've always perceived being a
public servant just that I serve you you
paid my salary this is an important
story more important than me my name
doesn't mean anything my face doesn't
mean anything the facts of what I saw is
what counts what it's like within the
cartel has a money launderer what it's
like dealing with the corrupt aspects of
the international banking a business
community is something that I think the
public needs to know exists and how and
why it exists and for me that became
something important that I wanted to
share and it kind of carried the rest of
the right before the closing credits we
see what happened to all the guys most
of them got 12 years they've passed by
now so they're out looking around so
we're dead mm-hmm moved on to new things
they scare still not happy probably did
you um I think that would be speculation
on everybody's part so you know all I
know is we have a burning desire to let
the story be told and you know where
that takes things and where that takes
like are you harmed when you go
actually you know retired federal agents
under under a statute are authorized to
carry anywhere in the country soon but I
don't talk about security or those
issues and I don't think they're
important I mean they're important to me
but I don't want to distract away from
from this year so any of privacy in
terms of the pacing it was excellent so
many you know biopics or you know so
many films are just too rushed or too
slow I felt the pacing was excellent
were there times when you felt like you
had to speed something up or change it I
mean it was just to me it was perfect
well then that Krampus crack oh we work
tirelessly in the Edit to you know
hopefully create an experience for the
audience that hooks you I always think
of like a great roller coaster ride you
get on and it grabs you right away
doesn't he go and to the right done and
in theory that was the goal to hear you
say that deeply appreciative because
that was that was where we were out as
far as wanting to make decisions in
every aspect of the frame and the layers
on it that going to make a movie that
felt purposeful whether that's the music
that's driving you whether it's the
emotional core that's driving you
whether it's the conflict that's driving
you whether it's the subconscious of the
imagery whether it's the editorial I
mean obviously all of these things
impact the final product but that
concept of having it feel purposeful
that you are being a lead through
something I cut a lot of that also to
David Rosen isn't he just a brilliant
editor that challenged me every step of
the way and we betting pens a lot but
out of that came a lot of really
exciting choices and changes
it was a wonderful crowd learning
experience hopefully for both of us I
think you really want to see what it
would feel like to be someone like Bob
undercover problem suitcase them but you
know with a recorder trying to get these
people and more tape so to not extend to
show that journey so that you're feeling
emotionally involved as a as an audience
participant to what he was experiencing
was a goal that we were trying to reach
how was it to work together oh I think
God state this earlier uh you know
uniquely challenging with respect to you
know as I've tried to explain to people
and I don't have this perspective of my
mom can't she can't turn off the mob at
it she's always going to be my mom even
if we're I look at it like we're having
this professional conversation and she's
the screenwriter and I'm the director
but in her head in her heart she stole
my mom so there were times that I would
be like oh well you're the screenwriter
how do I said you're the screen right
here you're not my mom and that was that
was really tough and rough for both of
us and for the most part I think there
are only two instances that I I just
almost turned upside down 11 was the
three of us we're developing the script
and my mom I think it's a great thing
actually and it's a good story it's
worthy of the education of it she had
written something that she deeply
believed in and that's what you want
from any collaborator that you're with
that they've created something that
they're like this is awesome if they're
not saying that then what are you
working off of so Bob and I came in and
we really tore it to shreds and I think
it was it was very difficult for her and
I just wanted her and I think was
delusional on my part I just wanted her
to sit there you know not say anything
and just you know do your job and she
was very combative in a positive way of
defending
she had done and you know there's no
question that was a learning curve of
like okay you know what I have to be
respectful the fact that she slaved over
this that she killed herself to create
this and even though Bob and I disagree
there's a much healthier way to approach
this and be sensitive to the fact that
we are changing something she believes
in and you know she is also my mom which
I have to keep perspective on so that
was it that was an interesting turning
point but I like to think sometimes
those things are good that they happen
if you learn from them if you change you
know you know the way you all interact
together to grow I mean there's no
question I think relationships in
general are defined by you know what you
ultimately go through good and bad those
are the real relationships if something
bad happens a relationship and then you
never talk again well I don't
relationship the jokes we really have so
I think the challenges and the negatives
that we traverse through we're defining
of where we ended up which is hopefully
positive we feel that way sitting here
proud to have them both side by silently
and then when I went opportunity to be
with the director and defend my position
I may not be tough to sit and they have
ten writers I know the main
me with you tried protected me and
believed in me which is makes me feel
very good also it's not across some time
I think about how protecting me with
this and believe in the writing what was
the greatest challenge for you um sadly
just having to get into production too
quickly and too soon and I think the
preparation is the foundation for
everything you also mundo do I was set
to make another movie and for multitude
of reasons it didn't happen and you're a
seagull did a wonderful job of melting
this very quickly and I just it's so
hard to get movies made in Hollywood
today I mean unless you are in a raw to
you know or Scorsese and even for those
guys is challenging but they're making
what they want to make and they're
making them how they want to make them
and I'm constantly a position where I'm
having to play a few sides against the
middle and pursue multiple projects and
I don't think it's the ideal way to work
I think we're at our best when we're
doing one thing we're doing one thing
well so in an ideal world which is up
when we live in would have just simply
been working just on the infiltrator
just in the infiltrator but we weren't I
was working on something else and when
the script was written I was off in
another movie and by the time this came
together I don't think we had really
fully unified we had done a nice second
draft that Bob and I felt had moved the
ball on the right direction and then she
began to embrace so we're all felt we
are in a positive place that was the
script that Brian signed on to the
second draft I mean for her because she
had prior workings with the
serves like death trap but I was not
involved and that's it for me it was
trip too so that was very difficult for
her but III think it was just all of a
sudden we're making a movie in on what I
don't think the scripture memory and
that was daunting the pressure of the
limited amount of time the pressure of
all Brian's notes coming in the pressure
of how daunting you know sort of Everest
was to climb with everything but you
know I you don't get to go into a movie
and make excuses prior to the lights
going down you know that's not how this
works you play your movie and nobody
cares about the rest of it so you know
it's interesting to speak of and maybe
educate others on but you know none of
that matters you lose you lose you when
you in you want thank you